tell me the bugs love what is to operate
on YouTube a lot of recons in for
premium service
perhaps you should ask why the nerve to
throw to third service if YouTube kept
its word in the first blows lease you
get talk who are you no matter whom ugh
father's what matters is our plan no one
care Dumont Cromwell's until I put on
the mocha you to just bans your channel
will you in my club just die cool you
seem like a big [ __ ]
[Music]
did he flag part of your plan of course
often do they monetize that channel
inside of the Unger well congratulations
you got caught the next step of your
master plan this is on YouTube my club
was created for the people to join and
the support of Santa Clara generated
content they will sign up another was
cousins Arkansas not one for the damaged
organ
I move on to a third route stuff what's
that
[Music]
now Isis is spared no expense this
Quraan double six six and I regret to
inform you we have received some
complaints regarding your expensive
taste and technical accidents so please
do try use of gentle hand with these
utilities I understand as I'm sure
you're quite aware by now things here
aren't always as they seem
for example take this what appears to be
an average daily wristwatch of course if
you look closely here there's a button
which when depressed acts as a
detonation device which will blow
yourself up so that sounds like
somebody's time is being cut short and
of course they say I'm particularly
proud of these appear to be your average
spectacles that one could be used for
nearsightedness if you look closely
there is a button which when depressed
that'll let you see things in the whole
new life do save your horrible puns for
the field double six six oh yeah
my most prized recent creation this
right here appears to be your average
everyday smartphone every when you see
this this home button device here when
you depress that you'll be able to blow
yourself up that will come in handy for
all the women are text before I read
this [ __ ] of them do crap double six six
of course this final piece was which
your mayor doubt familiar your beloved
Walther PPK now this would appear to be
a functioning firearm as any other wolf
Sahara when you see this this is usually
a magazine release button I'm depressed
they'll be below yourself up I feel like
I'm almost noticing a pattern here tell
me what does that magnificent hand
etched mug do that well that
unfortunately is mug club the current
our existence and the objective of your
next mission seemed a lot has been
spreading truth entertainment and
encouraging the American Way furthermore
even more alarmingly they've been able
to bypass our assistance from the
YouTube census able to reach communicate
with their listeners directly your
mission should you
hard to accept it is that trademarked
okay your objective will be to find who
was at the center of this mug Club
extract any information by any means
necessary
and destroy it to the dusters that mob
will break you
[Music]
there's no reasonable paper accepted
Louisville leader
[Applause]
why don't you just quit you to brain you
don't with an exodus you're welcome no
punishment must be more severe true not
just of your channel
Kano's unwelcome video platform honors
content here over the decades look to
the larger channels and aspired to
monetize so so simple menu creator have
been bandit Ryan know true despair
without hope so to terrorize YouTube I
will let them believe that YouTube can
simply be on our channel that they can
watch all the paring mock remembers
swarm YouTube with free content to stay
on the path you can watch his mock
remembers to shut into our internet and
then when YouTube and social media
Johnson understood the depths of that
no problem fulfill its destiny destroy
liberalism and then what it is done and
YouTube is awesome
got my permission for God
[Music]
stealing me in
is blackjack your game it's not so much
my game as it seems my kind of place
I'll stay you sure you don't want to try
for more when I see something I like I
know how to hang on to it
interesting philosophy what can you tell
me about that mug Club I'm just a girl
looking for a good time
hit me
are you sure that's what you want I'm
quite sure how the hell is bottle
prouder continue to grow when we just
stink we throttle the demonetised or
channel are they reaching their viewer
somewhere else or you think of patreon
where the hell is training babe I don't
know worry is the thought of it was are
you also you know what do you wear is
that the devil Dungy shall appear what
the hell is going on your plan is going
as expected
oh really does YouTube look advertiser
friendly right now your plan of parting
with see our TV it didn't work my friend
now your monthly members are supporting
line with Connor off-site but still
running around YouTube comments section
raising awareness and disrupting our
safe spaces tell me how exactly does
that help us YouTube get rid of
dissenting opinions Lumos no stay I'm in
charge
I'll let you monetize this on this gives
you power over me
what is this your YouTube and
infrastructure have been important till
now you are you mock lobbies YouTube
happening you are supported content and
not only allow us to return directly off
so it simultaneously disrupt the bubble
we've all been living in it is not club
outside of YouTube that allows the free
content to operate within YouTube you
are more business hell
[Music]
[Music]
I've been expecting you
jihadi Bond I was wondering what took
you so long to find me let's just say I
was well I hope she knows how to handle
that left hook of yours she did
unfortunately for her it was the right
you've always had a way of the lady he's
double six six well that's simply
because I always understood something
you could not then what's that what you
call charm I call raping and repeatedly
and beating them without mercy to put
that my notebook of pick up tips Mr Bond
enough small talk
who are you working for who is behind
this mug club you cannot stop it besides
it's not who it's what those wheels are
any motion of force which cannot be
stopped
we'll see what YouTube has to say about
this my club is a force beyond YouTube
it cannot be contained cannot be stopped
you really think that you do with all
its power with all its featured content
with all its Young Turks they could not
take care of your merry band of friends
what happens when your precious mug Club
is banned or worse they monetize my club
operates outside of YouTube outside
YouTube but that's internet suicide we
were right Mr Bond YouTube merely
provides shall we say the platform to
grow my club as YouTube continues this
jihad on free speech effectively using
its own power against itself as users
continue to join my club YouTube is no
longer needed to reach ones user base it
is suicide jihadi bond
with YouTube's finger on the trigger
I've heard enough who is behind this
supposedly unstoppable mug club you
still don't get it
it is not who
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
let me tell you the truth about
YouTube's guidelines in the words of
YouTube's own owners at Google content
that is not advertised of Saturday and
thus not YouTube friendly includes but
is not limited to sexually suggestive
content balance harassment proposes the
troubles and finally controversial
subjects including subjects related to
or political conflicts natural disasters
and tragedies evidence graphic imagery
is not shown any except the usual garage
do you accept these nylon de Deauville
rich leftists and all the correct
passive members of Marbletown
youtube from the pallet root social
justice warriors who have captured down
with these myths
[Music]
don't shoot century start by joining
$4.99 annually continued content and the
starving of YouTube step forward those
who will join for the Maghreb army will
be raised the powerful will be ripped
from their gelatin safe spaces and cast
out into the ground through speech skill
that we know and videos will continue to
be uploaded monetization through
sponsorships we better join channel will
survive and they want deserve true
freedom of speech yes this club it will
do so its membership the YouTube channel
will be allowed to survive
what can I do you for officer right
liebelei but this amount of vehicle is
for how are you oh I think that she's
had some miles on her but she's still
good for a few rides yet
I'm just having a laugh what's this
68 I can tell you're a man who
appreciate the classics very important
Edward o Pyramus not to ask what is your
purpose here in England I have heard
from afar the glories of your nightlife
and I intend to paint the town red well
enough for me there you go
be on your merry way just are you'll
find in London we are quite welcoming
that's not the problem that be none of
my business we'll meet judge because
I'll tell you that would be very
inappropriate at me
ah unless there's anything else you can
be on your way Thank You officer you
Tula
[Music]
let him come
run Johnny Gordon and I will kill her
[Music]
you
[Music]